all right 6 23 here it is Monday morning
Sunday though is Father's day and a lot
of us fellows be like a good solid state
for Father's day but here's the thing
most of the time you make dad make that
steak right so we're gonna actually
teach you how you can do it joining us
how to do that from Tom glicchio's craft
Stake Executive Chef Mike Chapman thank
you for being here as well as senior
general manager Greg gayhart welcome in
guys I know it's early and um we're all
trying to figure out how to use this
Appliance because Chef you've got the
goods at Christ's sake you know you know
how to make it work yeah so anyway uh
tell us about craft take first and
foremost is I've been on this trip for
such a long time it's a it's a staple of
MGM Grand absolutely we're located in
the MGM Grand we've been there for 21
years now
um we have a variety of cuts of meat
here
um that we uh specialize in yeah Chef
Tom clickio is our Top Chef sure that uh
curated our menu for us all right famous
name and good dishes yes yes I know John
has been I have not had the pleasure yet
so I'm gonna have to get over there
John's a big fan big fan love it tasty
stuff and I think it's important when
we're if you're cooking at home for your
barbecue by the way I think the heat's
on now because I'm sweating that's cool
that's the idea let's give it a shot
yeah so the first thing you want to do
is get your pan really really super hot
so you can we'll see
[Music]
what you want to do is to sear both
sides really really well to sear all
those fuses in there we generally don't
understand the uh the physics of cooking
that much so what happens if you know so
you gotta you got to sear those juices
in there we've all been there where you
where you think you cook the perfect
steak and you couldn't do it and kind of
it's raw in the middle right the flavor
bleeds out all over the plate yeah yeah
juice doesn't well we're going to show
you a couple a couple things you can do
to uh to minimize that okay so when this
is sizzling and yeah
imagination land okay so and then we're
going to put this in the oven for about
10 or 12 minutes uh medium at about 400
Degrees uh medium rare temperatures
between 113 135 degrees we're going to
pull that out a little bit early
actually going to sizzle it here and
then throw it in the oven that's right
that I did not know say 10 to 12 minutes
got it
all right so that's the key you bring it
out
so Chef that gives it that outdoor Flair
that outside flavor but then really kind
of cooks it on the inside by putting it
in the oven well this is the key to
everything resting your meat we talked
about the juices and how they flow out
um if you rest up these meat for 10
minutes that allows all those physics to
do work their magic really because
because when you put any protein on on
heat whether it be lamb or chicken or
pork or beef all the juices want to run
to the center it gets real hard real
hard solid Center and so you need that
that time to let that relax throughout
and repopulate the meat got it all right
and so so sizzle the outside yeah get
the juices encapsulated and then you
throw it in the oven for a little bit
and let the meat rest for 10 minutes let
it rest and then a couple minutes before
you get ready to serve it you want to
put it back in the oven to get it hot
for two minutes okay and you're not
going to overcook it that's the key is
that you have to pay attention these
times
oh look at that there we go oh look at
that beauty and then you can add some
garlic oh yes and some butter yeah
garlic and butter can't have enough time
and do some basting on that all right oh
and look at that and make sure your oven
works and if it doesn't work just go to
craft steak on FGM grand for Father's
Day and it'll be set up that way uh
gentlemen thank you for coming in Mike
Chapman Greg Gayheart from crab steak at
MGM Grand enjoy your father's day full
yeah enjoy yourselves yeah so glad thank
you